have you decided when you're going to
have your marriage
we decided may 9th may night
really yeah but that's also the weekend
of mother's day
here we go honestly from the look on
brandon's face
i think he might have forgotten that may
9th was even mother's day weekend
but regardless he pulled himself
together
and set his ground i don't care
if julie wants the ninth i'd i'm i want
to do the ninth based off of betty's
reaction
brandon might as well have said he's
getting married
on mother's day but he didn't
it's just the weekend plus julia
revealed the special reason
behind why she chose the ninth and it
makes total sense
we'll get to that in just a few but
speaking of
revealing yara also dished out some
pretty wild news about jovi
that might explain why she's so mean to
him
key word here is might i'm gonna trust
you after this
how can i burn your kids if i know that
you can leave me alone
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
first of all happy new year i wish you
nothing but great health
love and happiness in 2021
on the latest episode of 90 day fiance
brandon and julia dealt with issues
back to back before we get into
the wedding date drama let's start with
taking a look at
julia's first full day on the farm
while brandon was at work she
absolutely hated it
betty told me i need fork farm today but
i don't know how
i feel the smell and i won't throw up
this is not funny all smell here
okay so you're gonna have to get in
there yeah
all right you ready come on
julia cursed the pig out and then she
told it to stay
as if it was a dog and it was gonna
listen
that's hilarious well when brandon got
home
julia told him that she will not be
feeding those pigs again
she also said that she's at a point
where she wants to go home to russia
which is a threat we've heard from her
before
so brandon he's feeling the pressure to
tighten things up she told me that she
hates the farm
and i gotta figure out how to make her
happy and
how to make her feel comfortable here so
it's her home too
i really want julie and i be in good
moods because we're going to my parents
for dinner and she's going to meet my
granddad for the first time
[Applause]
so great to see you nice to meet you
kisses too slow your roll granddad
slow your roll
dinner with the family started off great
but then
betty lasered in on julia's neck
and spotted a hickey of course
she made it a big deal and treated these
grown engaged adults
as if they were 15. julia
julia your neck
oh my that's she invited me
you did not brandon
[Music]
how'd that happen you haven't been
sleeping in the same room mrs betty
we tried to tell you sleeping in
different rooms
wasn't gonna stop a thing i just can't
believe she actually thought it would
i can't believe you did that stop
embarrassing your son
no no i need to he's got he grow
up it comes with the eight yeah but
that's twenty he's twenty-seven
i'm eighty seven years old gonna be
eighty-eight
i'd still do that to a young girl if i
had one
anyway aside from the creepy comments
that brandon's grandfather was making
here and there
i'm glad he stepped in and said
something and julia
living with betty you now know that you
need to buy a bottle of makeup girl
so hide those bites in the future works
like magic
fast forward brandon and julia revealed
their wedding date
in both of brandon's parents agreed that
it's a problem a huge problem
it's just not a good day it's not it's
mother's day weekend i know
you don't want to share your day with
their day
terrible day to have a wedding thank you
i agree
okay it's one thing to think that may
9th
is not the best day to have a wedding i
get that
but to try to change the couple's mind
about
their special day all because it's not
convenient for you
you don't do that that's wrong when him
write me first mess
message date nine oh the day
was the night yes because him write me
first message
you look like my future wife you might
want to
rethink this and separate
your anniversary from mother's day i
don't care
if julie wants the ninth i'd i'm i wanna
do the ninth
[Music]
may second probably is the better day
i think she has good reason for winning
the night you know
it's all about perspective
because brandon's mom could have chosen
to look at this
in a positive light if she wanted to
she gets to celebrate her son finding
love
the same weekend she gets to celebrate
being his mother
it's all good things but
instead she chose to feel threatened
when i say what i want grandparents all
time said no no
no this is not good for you again don't
give me choice
again don't give me time for
say what i want may tonight may
just really date don't don't put it down
don't don't save the date yet we're
still working on it
i have a feeling that this is a battle
mrs betty
is not gonna give up easily so
good luck julia all right moving on to
yara
and jovi half of the time it seems like
these two
don't like each other but for some
reason they are still trying to keep
their relationship going
during this episode jovi is about to
head out of town for a month for work
just two weeks after yara landed in
america
leaving them 45 days to get married
once he gets back at dinner the night
before his flight
they started to talk about building a
family
and that's when yara broke down in
tears revealing some shocking details
about their relationship there is a
minor reason why i don't want to get
pregnant now
because when we were traveling in every
i lost a baby
and i was need to go for operation and
jovi left me and he fly along back to
work
you have to go to work but for your
woman's go to operation with your
kids he was not caring about no passport
or their country first of all not my
fault yourself
you lost your passport i had to go to
work you was getting called to work and
say i need to come in two days after
if there was some more of a situation
that i understood would be such a big
problem yes i would have but senior
julian this is stupid
you don't always need to go to operation
you're still leaving there
that's deep you know on the first
episode jovi did reveal
yara had a miscarriage but he managed to
skip
out on those details now it kind of
makes sense
to why she's built this wall of anger
towards him
yes a part of it is probably her
personality
but she could be trying to protect
herself
so she doesn't get let down by jovi once
again
i'm gonna trust you after this how can i
burn your kids if i know that you can
leave me
alone wow sorry what you want me to tell
you no i'm sorry jorvi
i didn't realize that yara was so
resentful to me that i left her
in albania i knew that i made a
questionable decision
i didn't expect it to be brought up a
year and a half later but
obviously it has been and obviously
their dinner was ruined
after this conversation but i'm glad
yara put her feelings on the table
no one deserves to just hold in that
much sadness and anger for
over a year especially when you're still
dealing with the person
who caused the pain joey's friend
sarah called me maybe she'd be nice for
jovi
well next week yara meets up with jovi's
longtime friend who seems like she's
going to make their situation
worse do you think jovi's ready to like
settle down
because i know like he was always out
drunk knew all the strippers disgusted
now i feel like i even didn't know him
wow she just
threw him under the bus all right
90 day fans fam to make sure you stay
updated on
all the latest news coming out of the 90
day universe make sure you stick with
e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time
you